Mình một thành chiến toàn toàn toàn toàn toàn toàn an cựu tổng thống của nước này
ông J. Bốn Soner of Humm y Mời năm 3 tháng 27. Sau khi kết tội ông Emm Mưu đạo trình
nhằm ruy trì quyền lực bất chấp thật bại trong cuộc bầu cử năm 2020.
Ông này hiện đang bị khoảng tuại ra, giới sự giám sát của các thi bị địa từ với tí lệ bò phíao ác đạo
bốn trên một hồi đông thường phán đã sát định ông Bốn Soner of Fạm nhiều tổng dễ nghiêm trong bà
của ông Tổ chức tội phản của chang, âm nư đạo trình, phán hoại trực thẻ và hủy hoại tại sản công.
Phản quyết không chỉ nhằm đến cựu tổng thống mà còn kết tội mầy cộng sự thân gắt trong
nó của những nhân vật tất cao trong chính quyền của như cựu bộ sường của phòng và cựu bộ trường từ pháp.
Chủ tịch hội đông sẽ sử thần phán Cristiano Gián Ninh cho rằng có bằng trưởng cho thấy nhóm của Bốn Soner of đã
cố tình cức động của Nội, cán thiệp, nế dưới chi quyền lực sau thích bại trước tổng thống lúc là đời xíu vá trong cuộc bầu cử
hình thống năm 2020, ngày sau phản quyết tổng thống mình đô năng trông đã linh tiến bảo vệ đúng mình
cả hiểu của mình trước đó ông trường cũng đã áp thị năm ở phần trăm, đối với hàng hỏi nhất cầu từ Brasit.